[Music]
hey y'all
and welcome to listeners this is rotten
tomatoes is wrong
i'm jacqueline coley i'm an editor at
rotten tomatoes where i cover
independent film and awards
and i'm mark ellis i'm a rotten tomatoes
correspondent stand up
comic and jaclyn in my place right now i
have
a little cupcake and some candles
because it's a very special day
that is right we are wishing a big
happy happy birthday to the man himself
mr
nick cage because thankfully
one of the first things we get to
celebrate in 2021 is the fact that it is
not 2020 and it's also nick cage's
birthday
he of course is the man who has never
found a line read that he could not take
to the next level
the comic book aficionado are would be
superman but
are absolutely the man that chased after
mandy with a chainsaw
mr nick cage and we're talking about his
film where he actually
steals the declaration of independence
national treasure
i'm so excited to talk about this movie
it is one of for those of you that call
me a curmudgeon and i see you
in the comments i see y'all but
i just want to say this is one of those
movies where i will let myself turn off
my brain and just
live and enjoy and i want to give a big
shout out to our fan
josh pickard i'm gonna hope that i say
that right
picard it's maybe it's picard you know
what i'm giving you the star trek
pronunciation because i want to
i thought you were worried about the
first name because it's like jossie or
justice yeah it's a it's a tough this is
a much tougher name to
to nail down than it was for nic cage to
steal
a certain artifact that is of value to
every american i'm not gonna genderize
whoever has the picard last name
i'm just gonna go ahead and say thank
you for emailing rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com
and giving us this recommendation
because i'm really excited about it and
i think most of the folks on the podcast
are but the movie let's just say it it's
at 46 rotten which is mixed to bad but
the audience which i'm a part of in this
episode
says it's 76 fresh as it
should be mark i just i i think i know
where you are on this but
hopefully you're gonna say the rotten
tomatoes is wrong national
treasure to me is a film that deserves
to be fresh in the tomato meter so yes
rotten tomatoes is very wrong in this
instance i'm not sure how
joshy josh pickard picard feels but if
they wanted us to talk about national
treasure i feel like this is one of
those
movies that we just we allow we we we
give it a pass
and then every time we sit down to watch
like oh yeah i kind of like this one and
it's just
great it's so much fun this is like the
closest thing
that we've gotten in cinema to indiana
jones
since indiana jones in the 80s though
you know what hot take as far as a movie
that gets you excited about history
and you learn things and it's fun leaves
india in the dust
fight me i don't care internet whoa i
think
our guests might agree with both you and
i about this one it's gonna be such a
love fest today because
we have not only a friend of podcasts
and friends of rotten tomatoes we have
an
incredible journalist mr marlo stern i'm
so excited
he is the senior entertainment editor at
the daily beast where you can find
all of his fun and witty pros but also
he's a self-proclaimed
nicholas cage super freak which wow i
didn't know that was a thing
but i want to be in that club so it's
gonna be a really great time
marlo welcome to the show sir hi
everybody thanks for having me
yes that was that was the reference to
the rock by the way oh
yes now i get it he's a chemical super
freak but he still needs a gun
in the rock and i mean there's a lot of
different sorts of things that he can
play around with as far as weaponry goes
in this movie his brain being one of
them
his family knowledge being one that can
be used for or against him but when you
look at national treasure here's your
quick synopsis is
you have this family and they're just
nuts
about this treasure that may be a myth
it may be something that goes as far
back as the knights templar but far that
predating even back to ancient times
and this treasure just continues to
accumulate as its new protectors
through the generations evolve and add
to it
but does it really exist in modern days
it just seems like we would have found
it we would have now come on we have
technology we would have found the
treasure
nicholas cage and his family line
believe it for the most part his daddy
not so much his grandpappy certainly and
so now nick cage is taking it upon
himself
with his merry band of people that he
some has to convince others are on board
the whole time others are
on his team and then turn on him sean
bean looking in your direction and it
all adds up to a fascinating movie where
the declaration of independence is
stolen
and that is just where the fun begins
will they find the treasure will they
survive
the attempt to find the treasure it's
all in a national
a treasure not as good as indiana jones
jaclyn but
a worthy follow-up oh really
okay i think well marlo do you agree
with me i mean i'm guessing that you
think that rotten tomatoes is wrong but
let me just go ahead and get it on
record right here and now
what are your thoughts on national
treasure i do agree with you i i will
say it's not as good as indiana jones i
mean there is
full-on nazi punching in indiana jones
you know i mean
i think indiana jones is better but but
no i do love
national treasure i mean mostly mostly
for the insanity
that is nicholas cage because i mean a
lot of the other actors are kind of
sleepwalking through this movie
including harvey keitel who i i mean i
don't know what
harvey keitel needed to get on but tommy
lee jones was on in the fugitive or
something because he is like on
sleeping pills in this movie i don't
really know well it's clearly a paycheck
for harvey keitel but i mean
no it's mostly down to nicolas cage's
greatness
yeah um nicholas cage's greatness also i
will say not everybody
is sleepwalking through this there are
there is some
i think doug from the hangover this
movie
is the reason why i was so upset with
what they did to him in those movies i'm
like this dude has stuff
let him yes justice for justin bartha
he is he he might be the star sorry i
know it's nick cage's birthday justin
bartham might be the best thing about
this movie
he is so note perfect as the
archetype the archetypic best friend
who also cracks jokes and doesn't really
have all the knowledge but he's just he
keeps
he's the voice of the audience in this
movie so he's kind of like an inverse of
the shakespearean chorus
and he just he kind of says what we're
all thinking throughout the movie and he
knocks every line out of the park so i'm
definitely giving justin bartha
full top billing for national treasure
yeah he does all the things that i wish
we got to see from emilio estevez in the
first mission impossible movie yes i am
still
mad spoiler alert that they killed him
very early but
let's take a trip back to 2004 because
we do need to get context on what
critics and audiences were saying why
there's such a big disparity
between what the critics and what the
audience thought about this film um so
with that we're gonna need tim
our illustrious review curation manager
to take us back there and let us know
what folks were saying
tim take it away thanks jacqueline so
national treasure is one of those movies
where you have the protagonists running
around looking for clues that are
historic
that lead to something much bigger that
goes all the way to the top
and it's not much of a surprise that a
lot of critics thought that it was
a derivative mix and for the negative
reviews there was a sense that the movie
was
so preposterous that you just can't
suspend disbelief
that in addition to being derivative it
was ridiculous
on the other hand the critics who liked
it said well yeah it's silly but it also
values people being smart over people
using violence and if it gets the kids
interested in history then all the
better
so how bad is that it's at 46 on the
tomato meter with 179 reviews and it's
got a 76
audience score and they made a couple
more of these so
it's pretty obvious people liked it
enough
um so what do the critics have to say
about this one in a rotten review
emmy russell of the portland oregonian
wrote that national treasure was a
decidedly less
exciting popcorn movie that tries to mix
indiana jones the da vinci code and
several strands of conspiracy theory
into one blandly entertaining package
on the other hand in a fresh review
carrie ricky of the philadelphia
inquirer wrote that national treasure
may fall a notch below pirates of the
caribbean on the pleasure-o-meter
but it does give american history sex
appeal and celebrates a guy
who relies on brainware rather than
gadgets
so we hold these truths to be
self-evident that it is impossible for
nicholas cage to be in a boring movie
but
as far as the merits go i'll leave that
to mark and jacqueline
thank you sir all i will say is i'm
you know they made another one people
like this
let's just enjoy the joy of this movie
and i know this is like such a twist for
me but
i didn't have a problem turning off my
brain for this one marlo what about you
i mean
is there a reason why this particular
movie when you watched it you're like
yep
this is why i'm digging it serve me up
some more yeah i mean you know
i just it's i think it's mostly down to
nicholas cage there are a lot of cages
in this movie um i kind of have to
disagree on the justin bartha tip
i mean i i do think he was better than
he was in geely
maybe but i mean i think
you know i think he's almost doing this
movie owes a lot to the italian job
which came out like a year and a half
before
and he's kind of doing an impression of
seth green in the italian job
but like kind of a worse version of it
he's like the guy in the truck who's
making sort of
quips throughout the movie um but but
you know i mean i do
i do think that tonally at least he sort
of is a good foil to diane kruger who's
playing it
very straight um which is which is sort
of interesting um
it's mostly down to nicholas cage
nicholas cage's highlights
in his hair nicholas cage just doing all
kinds of crazy stuff
is what i enjoyed about the movie that's
why i feel like bartho's such a great
anchor
for cage because cage has the ability to
just take these flights of fancy and you
kind of get to see early
real crazy eyes nick cage in this movie
a couple times and i think barth is just
like there to just to deliver
such a deadpan line to just bring
everybody right back down to earth and
so it's nice to have somebody like that
in the movie who
who believes in this war this
fantastical mythology
but also can like kind of speak for the
rest of us here it's like okay
relax nick we get it i will say this
though
before you like go too deep into justin
bar that the diane krueger i think is
also the problem with that because
she is so straight-laced it's almost
like depressing and i i don't want to
say there was a language barrier but i
just
she's in such a different movie like if
she's supposed to play elsa
from you know the last crusade or like a
version of that character
elsa looked like she was having fun she
was no
need um for her to have that kind of fun
at all on this one dr elsa schneider had
too much fun in the last crusade okay
she slept with both of the joneses
because we know that because she talks
in her sleep but i also think that this
makes sense for what
the dianne krueger character now i'm the
one defending this movie
is because diane kruger is she's like a
she's she's a curator at a museum she
like she takes care of old artifacts as
her job it's like
you don't necessarily think of somebody
who has that line of work
to be running around with nick cage
hunting treble
treasure all over the world so i i think
it does kind of work but
you know it's maybe i'm just excited
because i watched this movie again last
night
and i was reminded how much i loved it
oh no yeah she's very much the
straight-laced national archivist who's
kind of falls for nick cage and his pop
collar and his highlights and everything
you know she needs
she needs sort of something i'm gonna
let those highlights go
i'm just i'm just saying she needs some
sort of excitement in her life or
something and nick cage apparently
represents that
hey in the art world nick cage is the
baddest of the bad boys like he is
literally like let me be the rough you
know he's the marlin brando
in like streetcar named desire actor
version
of like archaeologist slash historians
but marlo
bringing up diane actually probably
brings up i think it like before you
were telling us that
even though she's off her offness is
actually part of one of your more
favorite scenes which
is the worst product placement i've
probably seen
in a movie that's supposed to be about
history there is
an almost five minute sequence in this
film inside of an urban
outfitters and you know we know that
jerry bruckheimer films are like
we know that jerry brookheimer films are
notorious for product placement
particularly the michael bay ones i mean
like i think in the first 10 minutes of
the island there's like
200 instances of product placement yeah
but i mean
you know in this film in particular it's
so odd because it's the only
major form of product placement in the
movie but it's so
blatant and it's so random it's like
after they get those
you know letters off the declaration of
independence or whatever whatever in the
national archives i think it's a
constitution or something at that point
i mean then they end up in an urban
outfitters changing
um and yeah i don't know it's such a
bizarre scene because it cuts to
nicholas cage and diane krueger
in changing rooms that are right next to
each other and you can
kind of see inside the other one they
can see inside each other's changing
room
and it's in the middle of the store so
everyone can see that i'm having this
conversation
it's just in the middle of the store and
the barrier is kind of
almost like right above where
you know their chests would be so just
the entire
store is watching them have this bizarre
conversation
and nicholas cage is kind of hitting on
her
while they're having while they're
changing in urban outfitters
i mean that's when you can do it that's
when you would do it exactly exactly
he's saying stuff like you know
has anyone have you ever told anyone
you'd love them before
and she's for some reason like digging
all of this like
this weird guy hitting on her in an
urban outfitters right after right when
they're in the middle of a mission
and then it's i don't know it's so
bizarre and it works i mean
she's digging it it's sort of it ends
with this shot
where her she almost goes into like on
point like about ballerina or something
where her toes
sort of like arch up and then there's a
direct like close-up shot of her foot
as it sort of angles up towards nicolas
cage and it's
really really bizarre so you get your
sense of absolute certainty from him
do you i'm sure i don't know what you
mean well you're
certain the treasure is real despite
what anyone else
thinks no but i hope it's real i mean
i've dreamt it's real since my
grandfather told me about it
i don't want to hold it i feel like i'm
so close i can taste it
but i just i just want to know it's not
just something in my head or in my heart
people don't really talk that way you
know
i know but they think that way
and then and then like i mean they spend
so much time inside of this urban
outfitters there's even
a sequence where nicholas cage is like
having this repartee with a hipster
cashier
who refuses to give him a hundred dollar
bill to look on the back of so that he
can get a clue but i mean the whole
the whole scene is just completely
bonkers wait
you're gonna love this excuse me can i
see one of those
hundred dollar bills i paid you with no
oh well uh here i have this uh diver's
watch it's called a submariner i dive
with it it's actually quite valuable you
can use it as collab
thank you on the back of a hundred
dollar bill is an etching of
independence hall based on a painting
done in the thank you in the 1780s
who and this guy the artist was actually
a friend of benjamin franklin's
it's wonderful i do love the bonkersness
of it though i
didn't love that one as much but i'm
curious mark
do you have the balls to you know put on
the full court press
in the middle of an urban outfitters um
is that the scene that
they could have clicked in with you well
for a bulk of this movie one could be
forgiven if they
suspect that the national treasure we're
looking for is actually under an urban
outfitters that the knights templar
had this whole thing set up and they are
the ones behind this
corporate entity that is masking itself
as a clothing store there used to be one
right next to the comedy store condo in
la jolla california
near san diego and you you'd go in there
just during the day just to kill time
before the show maybe look for something
to wear on stage that night
and there were a lot there was a lot of
cuteness happening in that store
and maybe you want to strike up a
conversation with someone their dressing
rooms are not normal
it's not like you're at sears or
jcpenney
and you just go to the far corner for
the dressing room the dressing rooms are
just everywhere
so it's a more socialized dressing
environment having said that
i totally forgot about that scene until
marlo just brought it up
it's amazing because then they're sort
of dressed in urban outfitters for the
next like
allegedly dressed in urban outfitters
for the next like 40 minutes of the
movie so i mean it's like
is urban outfitters sort of the treasure
hunting
you know what urban outfitters
let's do a little detective work
national treasure style
this is before urban outfitters was the
thing that it became in like the early
2010s
this movie was marketed to children so
is
this the movie that is responsible for
all of those kids being obsessed with
urban outfitters
about ten to eight years later
is this the movie that sort of like
inceptioned the hipster movement
i wonder if every child who saw this
movie
then seven years later went to go see
another john turtletop nicholas cage
team up the sorcerer's apprentice as
teenagers and were wearing urban
outfitters because it was just ingrained
subliminally
into their consciousness that's how you
get them you get them in the
hypothalamus with product placement
when they're six years old now as far as
the context of this movie
i think the scene works just because we
we know so little
about diane kruger's character the only
real hints we get to any backstory with
her
is when she receives a present from nic
cage after
he has this failed attempt to convince
her
in a meeting setting that hey somebody's
going to try to steal the declaration of
independence
he notices in her office she has
all of these commemorative buttons that
were george washington's
sort of the very first political buttons
and he says that oh
you're missing one nick cage happens to
have that one he sends that to her as a
gift
upon receiving the gift diane krieger
has this aside to her secretary
oh i hope it's not from this guy because
it was probably a breakup she just had
so let's not forget the fact that she's
coming off a breakup
and nicholas cage is not only a rebound
what better rebound than one that's
gonna put you in some danger
trot you across the globe and involve
you in the greatest treasure hunt of all
time
i mean that's a nice way of putting the
fact that he is literally just trying to
insert his you know
romantic aspirations into everything
that he is doing
in like ever an appropriate way how
because i just don't get them as a
couple
i just don't and like and you know what
it is
when there is already a better couple on
screen
that i'm shipping in my brain i have a
hard time
it's the whole when jen showed up on
dawson's creek thing
everybody knew that dawson and joey were
supposed to be together
or at least or at least at that point
anyway
but then jen shows up diane krueger is
the gen
and it is actually the justin barton
character that i want him
to that that's the real love story at
the center of national treasure if you
go back and look at it you can see that
it's there
is who bartha and krueger no bartha and
nicholas cage like those
two they are partners they went through
an extreme amount of trauma together
they almost
died together this is the stuff that
speed was made of
see i got a different one my couple
is actually a couple that goes through
all of the events that you might in
couple dumb
during the course of this movie and that
would be sean bean and nicholas cage
because
my my two favorite scenes my my number
one favorite scene in this movie is when
christopher plummer as the grandfather
of a very young boy who's gonna grow up
to be nicholas cage
have fun with that kid is he's
explaining
the history of this treasure and i just
thought that was such a great sequence
to lock you into exactly what this movie
is
that's one of those things that if i see
this movie in the theater my entire
large popcorn is finished by the time
jon voight enters the room and says hey
stop feeding my kid lies i wasted 20
years of my life on this crap
they're not supposed to be up here
looking at that
i just wanted to know
when you're old enough i suppose
you should know the story
okay here we go
it was 1832
on a night much like this
my other favorite scene is after the
breakup of sean being a nic cage because
they're looking for the treasure at the
beginning of the film
sean bean turns on his former friend and
now they're enemies through the film
but they're forced to team up one last
time
sort of to find the treasure they have
to work together to a point
and i love watching that i love watching
him and and this guy
their enemies they know that eventually
he's going to end with one of them with
the treasure the other one might end up
dead
but they have to work together because
there's no way
to get into this particular room
if they're gonna be at odds and and i
thought that was such a cool moment that
that's my favorite
part of the movie that's not a narration
explaining the whole thing
is watching them forced to team up right
before
sean bean tries to kill nicolas cage
again i have some questions
about sean beam in this movie i mean
well first off sean bean's hair
is the blondest of anyone in this movie
i mean it
changes lengths like four times yeah and
it's blonder than diane kruger i mean it
is the blondest hair in this movie it's
blonder than the wig
on john boyd's head when he pops out of
the attic um which i also wanted to talk
about but
i'm confused about sean bean's character
because i mean what is his motivation
other than being sort of a greedy [ __ ]
i don't really know
what i don't really know what like why
he's stealing the money or where
that's his motivation and goldeneye
that's his
sort of if you want to call it in
freaking lord of the rings he's just
greedy and he plays it well why are you
trying to read too much into it
it's true and he's british so he has to
be the bad guy in this movie
i read a lot into his care i think he
does love the lore
i i think that that bean's character
does care
about this and i think that he holds it
in a similar esteem to nick cage and
maybe that has poisoned his thinking and
is rationed out to the point of
villainry but i i think he does actually
give an
s about this stuff he's not just looking
for the gold to make a quick buck i
think he cares about the history of it
there's little
there's little looks that he gives
throughout the movie that i noticed upon
re-watching it where
it part of him is torn because he does
know how valuable this stuff is and how
much he
does care about finding it yeah i mean
look
i think that the sean bean character has
more to him than maybe we got to see in
this one he's just you know whatever the
whatever villain and i don't think sean
bean signs up
at that point in his career to do this
one well maybe it's post lord of the
rings no he doesn't have to he can do
what he wants
um but again not to bring it back to my
favorite odd couple
but the scene for me that like is the
reason why
we have a missed romantic comedy between
these two is the scene when they're in
the office with diane krueger
and you know cage is flirting with her
but you have just justin over there and
he's just like oh and that's the moment
when the fbi stopped listening to us
and and like he's looking at him he's
like should i tell her what i'm gonna
say about it being invisible he's like
no
don't do it that scene and the comedy
that they are willing to do in that
scene
and then that juxtaposition of diane
kruger not even doing the straight man
in a believable way
because she's almost a little bit too
like dismissive and weird about it i'm
like
either get in on the joke girl or don't
but that is the scene for me it's
absolutely hilarious it sets up the
whole tone for the movie and it's kind
of like
if you can enjoy that it's going to be a
good time if you can't enjoy that
then this movie is going to be lost on
you a map of what
the location of of
hidden items of historic
and intrinsic value a treasure map
that's where we lost the fbi you're
treasure hunters aren't you
we're more like treasure protectors mr
brown i have personally seen
the back of the declaration of
independence and i promise you the only
thing there
is a notation that reads original
declaration of independence
dating for july 1776 yes ma'am
but no map it's invisible
right and that's where we lost the
department of homeland security
also bringing it back to sean bean it's
probably why this movie is less liked
because he doesn't die in it
and and like i think that's like a
problem with it i don't know marla what
about you is there any is there any
other moment or scene where you were
like okay
this is why people need to give this
movie a second chance if they're maybe
like
unable to suspend disbelief with the uh
with the concept yes before i
briefly go back to marx scene in the
attic which i'm obsessed with because i
mean
okay so this is the cold open um
and you know young nicholas cage as a
boy is rummaging through the attic
christopher plummer sort of pops out in
a jump scare um
and scares the child and then he gives
the whole spiel on you know the whole
backstory of the film
and then jon voight pops up again jump
scare number two sort of
in just the most insane christopher
nolan blonde wig you've ever seen
and it's crazy because they didn't
de-age anything else about him
he still looks like a 60 something year
old
but they just put this like blonde wig
on top of his head and he's only nine
years older than christopher plummer
when they film this movie
so the fact that he's the son of
christopher plummer just looks
completely bonkers but
the scene i wanted to go to is uh the
national archives gala toast
where it's sort of this black tie event
nicholas cage you know
dresses up as a janitor to break into it
and then changes into his tuxedo
in his sort of james bond moment and
then
he gives this toast you know
holding a glass of champagne and it's a
toast and he's hitting on diane kruger
at the same time
and i know both my scenes involve him
you know clumsily hitting on diane
krueger but it's just because their
chemistry like you said
is bananas it doesn't make any sense um
it's negative it's like when you try to
put the two magnets together in
in middle school like it just doesn't go
i know so he gives he gives this speech
at the national archives gal he says you
know
to high treason that's what these men
were committing when they signed a
declaration of independence
had we lost the war they would have been
hanged beheaded drawn and quartered
and oh my personal favorite had their
entrails cut out and burned
and he yells he yells burned in like the
most nicholas cage way and she is just
you can see the reaction on her face
she's visibly put off by this and just
shocked
a toast yeah to high treason
what these men were committing when they
signed the declaration
had we lost the war they would have been
hanged beheaded
drawn and quartered oh oh my personal
favor
had their entrails cut out and burned
and then he sort of takes it back
and he sort of gets in a hushed tone and
says so here's the man who did what was
considered wrong in order to do what
they knew was right
and then he lures his voice to a whisper
and repeats
what they knew was right while looking
very intently
in diane kruger's eyes and then she's
digging it now she's like
for some reason vibing him back oh she's
there
again the things that are patty droppers
in this movie
in but she also is playing it's it's
nick cage
versus i mean if you think diane krueger
leaves a
her character leads a boring life in
this who's the stiff
that she is with at the party because
that guy is just a
drip of a human so anybody i don't care
how wacky you might be
anybody who's giving a lively toast is
now
the person that you want to be with the
rest of the evening over that dude
yeah i agree also can we also talk about
the fact by the way that dude was the
rock star of the archaeology histori
world before nicholas cage shows up that
dude is the guy that's like
that dude is the guy in um goodwill
hunting that's flirting with minnie
driver
before will shows up and he's like how
about them apples i love that dude
because he just
i love the fact when he gets embarrassed
also though can we give a big shout out
to
um john turtletop the director of this
mark
we love his movies the trash ones and
the really uplifting ones
we've talked about the meg which is i
think his greatest work ever
and when we can do this on the podcast i
will be so excited
he also though he did um uh three ninjas
driving me crazy uh a movie that i love
but not a lot of people saw a phenomenon
and the greatest romantic comedy ever
while you were sleeping i
this man is an underrated genius of our
generation is that all i have to say his
tomato meter averages rotten i mean we
can have a whole episode just on john
turtletop because he's only 48
on the tomato meter for all of his
movies that's his average he does have a
fresh audience average at 62 percent but
he's responsible
for giving us rocky colt tum tum and i
do find a lot of entertainment in the
sorcerer's apprentice he did
last vegas which was the old dudes going
to vegas for one last trip in 2013.
that's a fun movie the meg did leave me
a little disappointed though
as you know jacqueline you know i was
very excited about the mag and i was a
little disappointed about that
so i do think national treasure i you're
gonna hate me for this
i have not seen why you were sleeping i
love a man of comedy he's never seen
while you were sleeping
but as a beast by the way wait i'm gonna
say national treasure is his best movie
okay but i just have to say when you did
that for folks that are not watching us
on peacock which if you're not watching
us on peacock did you know you could
watch us on peacock
me and lucy's jaw dropped and we are the
same sort of slow
like oh and marla literally on the same
motion
as you were saying you have never seen
while you were sleeping it was
there marlo you got my back on this or
are you a while you're sleeping
i love while you were sleeping and this
is the time of year to see it it's a
christmas movie yeah
you know no i mean i love that movie
it's it's sandra bullock
you know working for the mta
and also built yeah bill pullman's great
and it no it's it's
it's delightful yes um also i
will go ahead and lucy um please say hi
because it's 20 21. i want people to
make sure that they know that you're
here
new year hi marla hi jacqueline hi mark
i'm so happy to be with you in this new
year and happy birthday nick
i love you yes happy birthday nick um
but
but i'm glad i'm bringing lucy into it
you know she's our producer so let's get
into
what they were saying about the film as
far as like
the industry inside of it because like
tim talked about it in his segment but
like everybody talked about how
derivative it is
and i know that is something that like i
get accused of
like saying a lot but if you do the same
thing it's not a problem if you're not
bored i've seen hundreds
of law order episodes and the formula of
that's still the same
somebody's going to jail at the end of
it and there's going to be like the dun
dun
but i can still watch them because they
find how to make it compelling even
though it's the same story every
time and so yeah this is derivative of
like you know the da vinci code indiana
jones sort of like
italian job find a treasure but i
thought it still did it in a new way
because it was geared
so much to the history and so much to
the kids i don't know what about you
marla
yeah i felt the same way and and you
know i just think there are
so many lovably insane nicholas cave
scenes in this movie i mean you know i
i another scene you know and not to get
another scene that i loved is the final
scene in the movie where
i'm pretty sure diane kruger drew
nicholas cage a map to where they're
gonna have sex
because uh because because the final
scene of the movie is them sort of
outside of a
you know stately i think british
mansion that they've purchased with
their money and um
and she sort of hands him a map and like
flirtily i think says you know you know
he's like what is this and she splitly
says you'll figure it out and then like
dances into the house
and nick cage chases after her so i'm
pretty sure that this movie ends with
diane kruger
composing a map to where she and nick
cage are gonna have sex in the house
or better yet maybe it's a map to her
own treasure yes exactly i mean
i feel like mom and dad are having a
conversation and and
and i'm just like listening and i'm not
really getting all the innuendo i i feel
like y'all are on a different point i'm
like oh sex gross i want to talk about
gold
no i mean there are just so many insane
scenes in this i mean you know there's
that there's that infamous scene where
he's dangling
diane kruger in the shaft and then just
sort of
basically tries to kill her i mean he
basically just drops her
in the shaft that's a great call that's
at the end it's near the end of the
movie and it's the dr elsa schneider
moment where indiana jones
um she so in indiana jones in the last
crusade indy's holding on to her there's
a crevice because they removed the grail
and so now the grail's dangling and elsa
lets her greed get the better of her and
it ends up making her slip out of
indy's grip and she falls to her death
into hell with this scene
diane krueger is being held by nicholas
cage she could fall to her
death but she's not greedy about it
nicholas cage gets a little greedy
because he wants to rescue the
decorative independent so
i i saw that scene and it's so funny
brought that up marlo because
he just does kind of chuck her and hopes
that she lands
on this wooden board that is still a
good 10 15 feet
drop but then the movie does such a good
job of keeping its tone
because right away he gets a decoration
of pennies he gets down he apologizes
and then her line saying i would have
done the same thing to you
it's it's almost like the men in black
memory eraser where the audience doesn't
remember this guy just chose a document
over
her a human life it makes it all okay
and we're all just fine with it now
we're back in the adventure that's
that's part of the magic of this movie
is we forget about any instance of
violence
that we might find unsettling otherwise
yeah because it commits to a tone which
is i think what was weird about like
people like nobody understood why this
movie made the money that it made
or the way it's like had this insane
cinema score
and the fact that adults were into it
more than kids that was the other thing
that like in mark's research when we
were sort of like
looking at um why this movie was such a
phenomenon as far as audiences he really
keyed on the fact that like
the people who mostly saw it were older
people
who liked the idea of going to see like
a historical treasure map movie and
although it did probably have a huge kid
audience too
it was part of that like what could you
go to see
as somebody who's got kids over that
pixar age but maybe under the age where
you could go see
adult movies with them you know this is
before those movies were at home
like you could you can find stuff on
netflix now that sort of fits into that
that sort of like sweet spot but you
couldn't find that necessarily back in
2004
and so i think that's why it was such a
thing but i don't know marlo were you
were you writing
entertainment in the 2004 time frame
were you part of the
of the internet journalist landscape
during that time
i don't think it was internet i think i
was writing for my college paper around
that time
but no i mean it's it it is funny and
it's funny to see
john voigt as a reluctant conspiracy
theorist considering that
considering that right now he is just a
full-blown conspiracy theorist
in real life so i mean you know it's
it's very funny to see him
you know have to somehow like ease into
the conspiracy theory part of
part of this film when right now right
now yeah he's just
you know he'll believe anything that
that you know you're his nephew
writes on facebook or something it's so
funny yeah he is the anchor in this it's
like
when jon voight becomes the the the
calming voice of reason in a movie
nowadays you're like oh my god we're
really getting out there
aren't we the people that got involved
in this nick cage plummer
uh harvey keitel uh john boyt
it's really interesting because all this
was like nick cage at the height of his
powers in a way you know this is
post leaving las vegas
post moonstruck where he established
himself as this sort of
um uh really established method actor
you know you know
people i remember after leaving las gate
vegas people were calling him the next
brando
i remember that so specifically and then
he just went
nuts pretty shortly after this and by
2009 he was running
haunted mansions and losing them in
foreclosure like this was the last
bit of nic cage normal
like i would say fair i don't know marlo
you literally wrote the book on the man
like
what do you look at his career and sort
of say it's fascinating because this is
this is
a film that may have changed everything
for nicholas cage i mean he almost
became his character in this film in a
very weird way you know i mean
nicholas cage around this time was when
he started snapping up mansions all over
the world
it really was like 2004 um 2005 when
nicolas cage bought like
a 40 acre island in the bahamas a
medieval castle in bavaria
and you know around the time right after
the making of this film he went on this
grail quest where he literally was
trying to hunt the holy for the holy
grail around the world and that led him
to buy
a sort of huge manner in rhode island
so i mean it was around this time that
his money problems started
you know in rhode island if if you're
looking at a grail diary like what sean
connery has
and the last page of it says and then
you'll find the grail in rhode island
i think somebody gave you a lemon like
i'm pretty sure i don't know a lot about
the holy grail i'm pretty sure i went to
catholic school i don't think rhode
island ever came up
in any of uh the grail quest did he like
marlo how close did he actually i'm so
fascinated with this and that's why i'm
glad national treasure didn't come out
when i was
like a little kid because this probably
would have set me on the path to become
like an archaeologist and i never would
have set foot on a comedy stage
thanks to this movie but did he
get close did he like like where did he
get
how far did he get in his matriculation
searching for the grail
i know it's bizarre apparently according
to cage he went to glastonbury
and sort of ended up in like a well or
something tasting water that was
allegedly in the chalice of christ and
then
and then yeah it brought him all the way
i guess to rhode island where he then
just purchased a manor and then sort of
he didn't get very far in the grail
quest and kind of gave up at that point
and said that it was basically all about
the friends he made along the way or
something
and yeah yeah but maybe that's why
taylor swift has a home in rhode island
too maybe she's searching for the holy
grail also
oh my god you are not how did you find a
way to put
t smith in a cage movie conversation
that's what i'm gonna think anytime i
see a rich celebrity buying property in
rhode island i'm thinking i know what
they're doing there
no they're looking for that that just
proves that that marlow writes for the
daily beast he knows where
he knows where those clicks are coming
from listen
i also am very excited about the nic
cage career just because
in the midst of what you could honestly
say is legitimately
the entire lifeblood of the podcast
which i would like to dub our sister
podcast how did this get made
i'm sure they could do like a nic cage
month if they haven't already you know
what i mean of like
seriously how did this get made but he's
about to do
a movie that is like his version of
remember the jean-claude van damme
jvd movie that he did which was like a
meta movie about his life or like paulie
shore is dead
he is about to do that and let me just
give you all the log line
and please understand why this is the
must-see movie for me
in 2021. a cash strap nic cage agrees to
make a paid appearance at a billionaire
super fan
birthday bash but it's really because
he's an informant for the cia
since said billionaire is a drug kingpin
and in doing so he gets cast in a
tarantino movie
take my money take all my money i'm in
mark do you have a favorite
recent post 2000 let's say
eight nic cage performance when he was
just doing whatever maybe one of his bad
movies that you love
or maybe one of his indie movies that
people haven't seen that's amazing like
mandy
i think nick cage is a phenomenal actor
and i'll say that
first and foremost i think he's got some
craziness in him i think he knows how to
play crazy as well to
to the cameras and to the audiences i
think that he's made a lot of choices in
his life that have led him to have to do
movies as opposed to wanting to do
the the plum rolls but it's so funny
when you look back on his career how he
fell
into being an action star because in the
rock stanley goodspeed is not
really the action cut that they're
looking for and that's a
running theme in the movie but he ends
up saving the day so now all of a sudden
he can be cameron poe and con
air and be like a true badass who killed
a guy and is in prison for it
but the movie that proved to me that
nick cage still has it that he's still
an a-lister when it comes to
acting chops is joe he was so
good in that movie and it's just such a
a heartbreaking dramatic
slow but you're you're into nick cage
the whole time and it's like
you know he's got that crazy thing but
within two seconds of him being on
screen and joe you're like
oh it's not one of those movies this is
gonna be nick cage like
doing an oscar-worthy performance what
about you marlo what's your
what's your plum picks from the later
part of nick cage's career
i know you mentioned the rock which i do
love that movie i know that's not from
the latter part of his career but i mean
which by the way the rock had uh
rewrites by aaron sorkin and quinn
tarantino on the script so i mean
you know i i love that film but but you
know i really got to give it up for bad
lieutenant port of call new orleans
which i think
the werner herzog film and the sequel to
bad lieutenant uh
shout out harvey keitel i guess national
treasure because but i mean you know
he his performance in bad lieutenant is
just completely
out of control and it's sort of he
really does go
he went full method allegedly for this
performance uh when i interviewed him
for mandy he said that
you know we discussed how he was so
method during the making of bad
lieutenant
that he was carrying around this little
vial of sugar around on the set
and just snorting from it you know
between takes
and at one point verner herzog went up
to him and he was like nicolas what what
are you doing
with the vial what's in the vial and
nicholas cage got really upset at
wherever
her talk for breaking his method and he
was like
you know after you burner get off my set
get out of my city it's coke
and um and you know it's uh
that sort of that little anecdote to me
really
um encapsulates the beauty of nicholas
cage he's
just so fully committed he gets an idea
in his head of a performance and a
character
and just goes full bore and is so
committed to it that'll go crazy
he seems to me to be like a golf course
to interview and what i mean by that is
you could play the same course
every day for a week and play and it
feels like an entirely different course
every day
is he is he cool and i never do this on
the show marvel but i'm just so
fascinated with nick cage
is he cool to talk to is he is he warm
is he receptive
does he have moods what is nick cage
like to sit in a room with
he's really cool to talk to it's almost
like interviewing
elvis in vegas or something because he's
sort of covered in
rings and has these big sunglasses and
is dressed
just really flamboyantly um so yeah i
mean it's
it is sort of like interviewing almost
like a vegas icon or something it's it's
very strange but no i mean he's
he's a nice guy and he's quite he's
quite you know soft-spoken
and um and yeah thoughtful guy i found
um i mean i didn't have a ton of time
with him
i was interviewing him for mandy which
is another one that
that i really love i mean in that one in
that one i believe you have nicholas
cage
snorting cocaine off a piece of broken
glass before sl
slicing the throat of a demon with the
broken glass so i mean it's
it's just it's just amazing um i mean
yeah i love nickels
yeah i was just gonna say i loved all of
your choices joe
shout out to that one that is such a
good cut for nicholas cage that not a
lot of people have seen
i was going to say mandy because i love
that movie and i actually saw that movie
at 8 a.m
at sundance stone cold sober which is
probably the worst and best way to see
it
because every bit of its weirdness just
washes over me so folks please check out
mandy but actually the role from his
later work that i like the best
and it's the shortest role in the world
but i love it so much
he plays spider-man noir in spider-man
into the spider-verse and it's part of
that like
vignette of all the various like you
know when all of the other spider-man's
come
i want an entire movie of spider-man
noir so bad i can taste it
i want that movie maybe even make it a
short i don't care because
there is just so much there a noir
spider-man just think about that think
about the funny
quippy noirs that you would get with
like billy wilder
and then make him a freaking spider-man
come on
[Music]
like you know i don't know are you with
me on this
i don't know so i i love that one but
you know hey look this is a guy like i
was reading um
one of the articles he's in on the joke
like yes he had to do a lot of things
for financial but he's making these
choices i mean
he'll go do something like mandy and
teen titans go and spider-verse
and then he'll go do like some weird
movie that is
literally straight to dvd that nobody
talks about he just
i think he just likes doing movies that
are weird and fun and if he's gonna have
a fun time doing it he'll do it
he was nominated for adaptation in 2003
that was the last time that he was
nominated for an academy award obviously
he won for leaving las vegas but
i i've always said this i think that if
he continues to enjoy acting continues
to
pursue it i i think that he's got a
couple more at least nominations in him
i think he's going to be one of those
actors that you talk about and
maybe not necessarily have a career
resurgence in terms of box office but i
think that
if you get nick cage at this point in
his life
in even a supporting role i think that's
a home run depending on what kind of
move you're making
i think he's still a very versatile
actor and i think he can pull off a lot
of stuff
and more national treasures we might get
more national treasures like
bob iger teased it in like 2016. i don't
know why it's taken this long because
the first two movies
were hits the the second national
treasure book of secrets did better at
the worldwide box office than the first
national treasure so
where is our national treasure three i
have a question too this is producer
lucy
why do you guys think he's become this
kind of like
living myth legend you know that he is
now like
why him and how did this happen because
he's kind of
this mysterious figure and i'm always
just so fascinated by him
yeah he really just has always leaned
into the the wildness i mean there are
so many stories about nic cage
too just that are so bizarre and that
have fed the mythology kind of like bill
murray's pranks on people there are just
so many weird little stories
like the time that nick cage in new
orleans was bailed out of jail by dog
the bounty hunter
or like the time really wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
can we just take a minute to picture
those two
driving off into the sunset with those
hairlines
yeah it's it's it's just bizarre or like
yeah his different hair
in different movies um or like the time
he bought a
dinosaur skull of a tarbosaurus for
nearly 300
000 and it was stolen and he had to
return it it's just
you know he is he is sort of a larger
than life figure at this point and it's
or i mean the time when he was shooting
ghost rider 2 in uh romania and he was
getting kicked out of a romanian
nightclub and
yelled i'll die in the name of honor
i mean he's just done so many amazing
things that he's
he's just a folk hero at this point my
buddy josh mccooga was on a private
plane with him going to las vegas a
couple years ago
it was just one of those like like jets
where they just jet sweets and they just
oh now you're in a private jet
and he was with nick cage and he said
nick cage he didn't really talk to
anybody but what he wasn't mean
and makuga knowing he couldn't resist so
once the plane lands
nick cage has a car waiting for him on
the tarmac and
josh just goes over to him and he says
hey man i i just wanted to let you know
um you would have been great as superman
and i loved you in john schnapp's
documentary
our buddy john schnepp who passed away a
few years ago made the documentary the
death of superman lives what happened
and nick cage reportedly was a fan and
and had said complimentary things about
that documentary
that has footage of him in the suit and
so
nick turned around when he heard john
schnepp's name and he said oh yeah john
schnepp was a really cool dude and then
he got into his car and drove off into
the night and to hear josh tell it he
says i was kind of thinking nick was
gonna offer me a ride to the strip
he didn't but he still got to have a
nick cage story which is really cool and
everyone should check out the death of
superman liz what happened
it's a great documentary when you said
nicholas cage being greeted by a car on
the tarmac i pictured that scene in face
off where he's sort of
sort of given the box with the gold guns
in it and the tic tac
or the chewing gum and the other stuff
caster troy is is probably where nick is
like you know what this
this flare i think i'm going to keep
this for my real life too
i actually think it's earlier people
forget vampires kiss
like i think he's always done crazy
movies it's just a lot of them turned
out to be really great because if you
look at something
like vampires kiss like that is a nuts
movie that's just a nuts movie
and yeah there's there's there's a lot
of things that he did
um that i'm like people should pay
attention he was not caring about the
roles that he was taking
way back when uh i don't know and the
the voice he did for peggy sue
yeah which was just like he just
randomly did that and kokolo was like i
mean fine
but yeah fine find nephew
whatever you want to do was that his
last coppola movie too right maybe
i think that may have been the last one
anyway
um but i just imagine francis francis
just like hey you know what nick we work
better as a trivia question
than we do as director hey he gave him
his start though so
he put him in cotton club you know he
was in rumblefish
he made it he made him he made him what
he is but hey you know what
for folks that that want to take a trip
down the lane of
nick cage's later career don't believe
the hype
check it out for yourself there's a ton
of really great stuff in there also
color of space which is one from this
past year that's incredible sci-fi movie
um marlo lucy mark of course everyone
um thanks for this this was really fun
uh marlo
before we go though i want to ask you
since you're an entertainment journalist
a senior
entertainment journalist uh what are you
recommending for folks to watch because
it seems like we're gonna need some
recommendations to watch stuff at home
for just a little while longer so
what can folks do yes i mean i would i
would recommend against the undoing
which i
finally finished recently on hbo
and which is good for the first few
episodes but then it just goes down
some very strange david kelly
uh territory but um one thing i would
highly recommend people watching is
murder on middle beach if they haven't
seen it it's a really fantastic
docu-series on hbo it's only four
episodes
and it's about this um young man whose
mother was
was terrifically murdered in a suburb in
connecticut
but then he sort of starts investigating
the murder on his own
and uncovers this really vast conspiracy
involving
all his relatives so it's it's really
fascinating and one of the best
true crime docu series of the year and i
would highly recommend it i gotta check
that out yeah what's the name again this
is
murder on middle beach on hbo about this
i'm about this all right
and uh marlo where can folks find you
and what have you been working on i know
you know you always have stuff on the
daily beast but what should folks be on
the lookout for
yeah let's see um i did a really
interesting interview with the actor
nick stahl
which should be running this weekend
he's the guy who played uh john connor
and terminator
uh rise the machines and um was the lead
on carnival and was on bully
and uh was you know quite a quite a big
actor for a while but then
you know fell on some hardships um found
himself on skid row
and battling drug addiction and really
left the industry for about
seven seven or eight years and is now
making a comeback
so uh i think it's an interesting
profile and that should be running
this weekend so i was it was nice
talking to him and he seems like a good
guy
yeah actually i'm very interested in
that he was also uh the yellow dude from
uh sin city yes after dicaprio turned it
down
yes um yeah that's so crazy that that's
the way that goes
um yeah well thank you again marlo this
was really fun
um anyone if you by any chance have not
seen national treasure the first or the
also very good sequel you can watch both
of those on fandango and voodoo
voodoo they're available to rent or
stream
you can of course follow marlo on the
social medias
at marlownyc you can follow me at that
jaclyn on all forms social media and you
can follow
mr mark ellis at mark ellis live mark
you have some shows coming up right or
no
you won't i'm still working we're still
we're still working on maybe a new
virtual show but i'm probably not going
to get back to full touring until the
summer at the earliest but
it's a big year for me already because
now i know someone personally named
marlow i think it's one of the coolest
names you could possibly
give to a kid and so marlo i am thrilled
that you are the marlowe
in my life welcome thank you thank you
i'm thrilled too
like when you have a name like marlo you
got to go like right for the daily beast
like you're you're saying to that kid go
do something interesting and hipster
because the name
says that's what you need to do i don't
hate a marlowe
that's investigating and i don't hate a
marlow that's looking for maybe
treasure for maybe secrets unearthing
archaeological facts marlo is a cool
thing for that
yeah it's like you know elon musk's baby
needs to be an alien at this point
because
listen before before before we start
writing our own
uh screenplay for national treasure 3
which by the way it would be
fire we want to remind all of you
wherever you're listening
to us please rate and subscribe tell
your friends and
this episode was the result of our
friend person with the last name picard
because we still are a little bit unsure
about that yeah
um they emailed us and recommended it so
please do that you can email us at
rotten tomatoes is wrong
rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com that
is rt is wrong
at rottentomatoes.com we want to hear
what you guys are
saying on behalf of lucia our producer
tim
ryan mark hoffmeyer my co-host mr mark
ellis and our very special guest this
week
milo stern i want to thank you all for
listening i'm jacqueline and we'll see
y'all next time